[Musique]
bonsoir il est 18h si vous nous
rejoignez en direct pour cette nouvelle
édition du 78 nous allons parler de la
rentrée des classes en compagnie du
recteur de l'académie de Versailles
bonsoir Alain boossino merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation ce jour de
rentrée une année de transition une
rentrée de transition c'est ce qu'on
souvent du côté du gouvernement est-ce
que c'est le cas est-ce que sur le
terrain on peut parler de rentrée de
transition oui c'est vrai que c'est une
année qui se caractérise par les
opérations habituel de rentrée scolaire
mais qui se caractérise aussi par des
débats des réflexions sur un certain
nombre de de projets qui correspondent à
ce que le ministre appelle la
refondation de l'école donc c'est une
année où on travaille sur les semaines à
venir mais aussi sur les années à venir
donc ça fait un programme chargé on va
parler de ces différents dossiers avec
vous durant la première partie de ce 78
nous parlerons également avec vous
Maxime bonsoir journaliste à la
rédaction de TV fil de cette rentrée des
classes vous avez suivi une enseignante
des élèves dites-nous en plus une
enseignante des élèves une enseignante
stagiaire deux enseignantes stagiaires
que j'ai suivi pendant leur journée
d'accueil que j'ai suivi pendant leur
rentrée des él 8h du matin vous étiez
avec les élèves tout à fait tout à fait
avec des petits bout de chou des petits
bout de chou en maternel allez on les
entendra à tout à l'heure c'est bout
dechou et puis ce soir nous feront aussi
le point sur la participation des
athlètes yvelinois au Jeux parallympiqu
de Londres vous découvrirez l'invention
d'une société du département qui
développe un concept de réalité augmenté
mais en piscine pour l'instant voici un
aperçu en nimaged reportage de ce soir à
la rentrée des classes donc avec ce
portrait de Caroline Guillard jeune
stagiaire elle a fait la rentrée sa
rentrée ce matin dans une école de
voisin le Bretonneux en primaire en
maternelle ils sont plus de 160000
enfants à avoir repris le chemin des
cours dans les Yvelines le point complet
sur les effectifs pour cette rentrée
2012-23 à suivre des effectifs en hausse
le coup de la rentrée les fédérations de
parents d'élèves s'inquièes plus 2,9 %
par rapport à 2011 il faut compter 193 €
pour un élève rentrant en 6e Doren avant
et puis le cinéma du grenier à C la
trappe à lui aussi fait sa rentrée une
rentrée tout en numérique avec la
transformation de la salle pour une
diffusion en très haute définition
toutes les explications avec son
directeur galpino qui sera sur ce
plateau tout à l'heure le directeur du
ciné7 Luc bean sera d'ailleurs lui aussi
avec nous ce soir puisque les travaux de
rénovation dans son cinéma ce cinéma D
cours ont pris beaucoup de retard une
année de retard en politique je vous le
disais hier Henry Guenot candidat député
de la 3e circonscription des ivelines
ancienne plume de Nicolas Sarkozi euh a
annoncé sa candidature pour prendre la
présidence de l'UMP et dès demain à 18h
en direct dans cette édition vous
retrouverez sa déclaration ses
explications son choix pourquoi il a
choisi de se porter candidat et nous
l'entendront également se prononcer sur
le soutien de Valérie pécrè la chef de
fil de l'UMP dans le département à
François Fillon l'ancien Premier
ministre pour l'instant on passe donc au
fait du
[Musique]
jour Alain boissinau et l'invité donc du
78 pour débuter le recteur de l'académie
de Versailles on va revenir sur les
différents dossiers de la rentrée avec
vous tout d'abord les chiffres forcément
les chiffres des chiffres en hausse je
le disais tout à l'heure plus d'élèves
cette année dans l'académie oui un petit
peu plus l'Académie est considérable
hein c'est 12000 élèves mais c'est vrai
que la tendance est à la hausse dans le
premier degré on gagnera sur l'académie
environ 3500 élèves et elle commence
aussi à se réorienter à la hausse au
niveau des des collèges donc dans les
années à venir l'académie de Versailles
et le département des ivelines comme le
reste de l'Académie seront en en
augmentation démographique comment vous
expliquer c'est cette augmentation c'est
démographique il y a des nouveaux
arrivants dans les différents quartiers
les ivelines SD ou il y a il y a des
phénomènes d'attractivité des territoire
et puis il y a aussi les les
conséquences du fameux baby boom de l'an
2000 vous savez que la natalité en
France plus importante que dans beaucoup
d'autres pays européens et ces jeunesl
ces jeun sont des jeunes qui ont
parcouru l'école primaire qui arrivent
maintenant au collège donc nous sommes
très heureux de les accueillir en grand
nombre grand nombre d'élèves est-ce que
les moyens aussi suivent est-ce qu'il y
a une augmentation des moyens pour cette
rentrée ben vous le savez le
Gouvernement a souhaité nous donner un
un coup de pouce dès le début de de
l'été donc notamment dans le premier
degré puisque c'est là que nous avons
les élèves les plus nombreux à
accueillir nous avons pu répartir dans
l'académie une centaine de postes
supplémentaires 22 dans les ivelines ça
a été un un ballon d'oxygène qui nous a
permis de confirmer un certain nombre
d'ouverture de classe ou de revenir sur
des projets de fermeture qui avait pu
être être envisagé et j'espère qu'on
continuera sur cette lancée dans les
années à venir pas de blocage ce matin
les diff con bien pass vouszs C pour le
moment les choses se passent bien et je
suis un reeur sereinz on parlerit des
chiffres justement on va faire un point
avec ce petit reportage un point sur les
chiffres les chiffres qu'il faut retenir
de cette rentrée 2012 dans l'Académie de
versaill
quelques 297000 élèves ont fait leur
rentrée ce mardi matin dans les Yvelines
plus d'un million dans l'ensemble de
l'académie de Versailles des effectifs
en légère hausse par rapport à l'an
dernier la progression la plus
significative est à chercher dans le
premier degré pour accueillir ses élèves
on annonce du côté du rectorat des
moyens en hausse 100 postes de
professeurs des écoles supplémentaires
dans l'académie 22 pour le seul
département des ivelines toujours dans
les ivelines on compte 40 emploi
d'assistant d'éducation en plus ces
postes dédiés à la vie scolaire et d'ici
à la fin 2012 des assistants chargés de
prévention et de sécurité des APS vont
aussi être recrutés sur la volonté du
nouveau gouvernement ils seront 500 en
France 46 dans les qu départements de
l'académie à se charger d'agir contre
les violences enfin un dernier chiffre
l'Académie emploie cette année
900923 personnes dont plus de 39000
enseignants en collège et
lycée RG et j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête
pendant quelques instants sur ce qu'on a
entendu dans le dans le reportage le
recrutement à venir des APS des agents
chargés de prévention et de sécurité il
y en aura 500 en France c'était une
volonté du gouvernement 46 à peu près
vont être recrutés dans l'académie d'ici
la fin de l'année ça va consister en
quoi alors l'idée est simple ça fait un
certain nombre d'années que nous
essayons d'aider ceux des établissements
qui rencontrent le plus de difficultés
notamment autour des problèmes de
sécurité et de violence nous avons dans
l'académie un un centre qui est chargé
avec un ensemble de de compétences de
répondre aux besoins aux appels des
établissements qui ont besoin d'être
accompagné face à ces difficultés et là
nous allons avoir la possibilité grâce à
ces assistants de prévention et de
sécurité d'avoir non seulement une
ressource prête à répondre à la demande
mais d'avoir ça ce sera une nouveauté
des personnels compétents et formés nous
allons les former dans les de mois qui
viennent qui seront à demeure dans les
établissements les plus difficiles pour
aider les chefs d'établissements et
leurs et leurs équipes nous allons donc
avoir tout un ensemble de de moyens
d'accompagnement à la disposition des
établissements pour éclairer le
téléspectateur quand on parle de
sécurité il s'agit de d'agression qui
viennent de l'extérieur ou alors de
sécurité entre les élèves il y a des
problèmes de alors les les deux cas
peuvent se présenter hein nous avons
effectivement des problèmes qui peuvent
être des problèmes de tension internes
aux établissements des phénomènes de
raquettes des phénomènes de conflits
entre élèves hein qui concernent les
élèves eux-mêmes de l'établissement à
l'intérieur ou souvent aux abords des
des établissements et puis il peut y
avoir dans certains quartiers des
phénomènes qui sont liés à l'intrusion
d'éléments extérieurs dans les
établissements donc c'est en effet surt
cela qui se joue souvent aux abords
immédiats hein de nos de nos collèges ou
de nos lycées c'est surtout cela qu'il
faut agir et quel profil alors pour
recruter justement ces futurs aps alors
on va chercher des candidats qui doivent
avoir déjà un certain niveau de de
formation on les recrutera au niveau
bac+ 2 on les recrutera pour leur
intérêt pour les questions de vie Scola
pour leur intérêt pour l'accompagnement
des des jeunes et on leur donnera
pendant les 2 mois qui vont venir une
formation qui leur permettra de mieux
connaître le fonctionnement de nos
établissements de connaître les les
différentes situations auquelles ils
peuvent avoir àire policiers ce sont pas
des vigiles non plus quiison en fait ce
seront des personnels de l'Éducation
nationale mais qui travailleront en
liaison étroite avec éventuellement des
responsables de la police ou de la
gendarmerie vous savez que nous avons
dans la plupart des des établissements
des relations étroites et confiantes
avec les services de police et
gendarmerie qui souvent désigne des
référents auxquels l'établissement peut
faire appel en cas de de difficulté
l'idée c'est d'avoir toute la gamme des
réponses possibles pour faire face aux
différentes situations qu'on peut
rencontrer et le recrutement est en
cours le recrutement est en cours c'est
facile de trouver ce type de profil
justement euh je pense que compte tenu
du niveau de formation et compte tenu de
la motivation qu'on demande il va nous
falloir effectivement faire connaître
cette possibilité donc merci de me
donner l'occasion de le faire hein ce
soir et les personnes intéressées
peuvent s'adresser soit au chefs
d'établissement parce que les chefs
d'établissement recruteront soit au
rectorat nous avons un centre d'aide aux
écoles et aux établissements qui va
organiser l'ensemble de la campagne de
recrutement le recrutement donc est en
cours on va s'intéresser tout de même à
l'humain on parle du côté technique de
la rentrée avec les chiffres mais Maxime
vous vous les avez suivi ces enfants ces
enseignants qui ce matin étaient dans
les classes un peu d'humain au milieu de
tous ces chiffres ou tout à fait tout à
fait j'ai suivi plus particulièrement
les enfants et les professeurs de
l'école du bois de la Garenne à voisin
le Bretonneux alors plus
particulièrement une professeure
stagiaire qui s'appelle Caroline
Guillard alors pour c'était une journée
extrêmement importante puisque comme
beaucoup de professeur elle considère
que la première journée le premier
contact avec les élèves ça va déterminer
finalement la relation qu'elle va avoir
avec tout avec ses enfants pendant
l'année bon c'est la première fois
qu'elle se retrouve face à 25 élèves
elle avait un peu peur elle avait un peu
peur elle elle était pas très rassurée
elle était pas très rassurée pour être
tout à fait honnête donc je l'ai vu la
veille de la rentrée et je l'ai vu le
jour de sa rentrée euh il y a quand même
une petite chose dans sa formation qui
l'a aidé à bien appréhender euh cette
journée je vous laisse deviner de quoi
il s'agit regardez ce
sujet cartable sur le dos vélo à la main
retrouvaill entre copines pas de doute
comme partout en France au groupe
scolaire du bois de la Garenne
aujourd'hui c'est la rentrée hier encore
l'établissement vcinois était
pratiquement vide seule activité les
derniers préparatifs avant le jour J
Caroline Guillard a 28 ans elle est
professeur stagiaire et pour la première
fois elle va se retrouver devant une
classe de 25 élèves de maternelle âgé de
4 à 5 ans pour le premier jour des
bouchou elle n'a laissé aucun détail au
hasard un moment d'accueil autour de
jeux divers dans la classe ensuite un
moment de regroupement où on va se
présenter chacun notre tour à la fois
les élèves qui se connaissent déjà mais
également les nouveaux et moi-même bien
sûr puisque moi je vais être la nouvelle
maîtresse ici pour devenir stagiaire
Caroline a suivi un master de professeur
des écoles à l'université Versailles 5
tin elle a bénéficié d'un dispositif en
alternance grâce auquel elle a eu en
charge tous les lundis une classe de CE2
pendant un an malgré cela elle estime
avoir encore beaucoup à apprendre sur le
niveau
maternel une demi-heure avant l'arrivée
des élèves Caroline est confiante je
suis arrivée à 7h30 en arrivant j'ai
disposé les étiquettes sur les portesmau
j'ai préparé les différents jeux pour
l'accueil sur les tables et dans les
différents coins de la classe une
préparation qui semble avoir aux enfants
un dernier coucou aux parents et c'est
parti pour une année qui s'annonce riche
en nouvelles expériences pour tout le
monde comment tu t'appelles atin
Augustin Paul
pa Martin et donc c'est exactement à ce
moment-là qu'on a quitté Caroline voilà
quand elle était en train de faire son
sa première premier rassemblement avec
les élèves donc on a entendu parler de
la formation en alternance à un moment
où quand même entend beaucoup parler
dans dans les médias dans l'actualité du
manque de formation enfin que ressent
certains professeurs c'est important ce
type de de formation c'est très
important euh on a un grand débat dans
notre pays sur la formation des des
enseignants et c'est un des axes
principaux annoncés par Vincent payon
que de travailler à réorganiser refonder
la la formation des enseignants et ce
sont des des sujets dont nous nous
sommes saisis dans l'académie de
Versailles notamment avec les collègues
de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin he la la jeune enseignante
là il faisait allusion et nous avons
expérimenté ces deux dernières années un
dispositif dont nous pensons d'ailleurs
qu'il a vocation justement à à servir un
peu de de modèle pour la réforme à venir
qui consiste à commencer le plus tôt
possible à préparer les enseignants à la
réalité de la vie des écoles et des
établissements et donc au lieu
d'attendre qu'ils aient passé leurs
diplôme pour leur donner une formation
professionnelle l'objectif c'est pendant
la préparation du diplôme de leur
permettre une journée par semaine de
travailler auprès de leurs collègues
avec un conseiller pédagogique dans une
classe et de découvrir peu à peu la
réalité du du métier alors ça permet de
de démarrer le jour de la
rentrée certes avec encore un peu de
tracin mais c'est normal mais avec déjà
une bonne préparation va-t-on assister
au retour des ufm je vous poserai la
question tout à l'heure voir un petit
peu vers quoi on s'achemine sur les
prochaines rentrées j'aimerais juste
qu'on entende les enfants qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure on les a vu ils avaient
l'air sages avec leur enseignantes voilà
alors on les a entreaperçu vous allez
les voir maintenant dans un micro
trottoir devant l'école quelques pleurs
quelques moments deà non je l'aurais pas
fait peur j'aurais pas fait peur je
l'urais juste demand untit peu comment
s'était passé les vacances ils étaient
contents de retourner à l'école bon dans
l'ensemble ça on pourra revenir dessus
après je pense au rythme scolaire
beaucoup avaient oublié ce qu'ils
avaient fait en début de vacances que ça
veut dire que les vacances sont trop
longes en tout cas regardez les enfants
sont contents de retourner à l'école
alors est-ce que tu peux me raconter
comment c'était les
vacances je me rappelle plus que
ah formidable à ce point là qu'est-ce
que tu as fait fait
euh on est allé à plus on est allé chez
les grands-parents ouais je suis allée à
la montagne je suis allé au lagcachard
ouais je suis je suis allée à Fréjus et
je suis allé et et puis j'ai fait du
bateau on est allé on a fait de la
piscine on est allé à la plage on a fait
de l'escalade et c'est pas trop dur la
drit venir à l'école euh non non
pourquoi est-ce que tu veux revenir à
l'école parce que j'aime bien l'école
ouais qu'est-ce que tu aimes bien à
l'école
bah la récréation et de travailler ouais
surtout la
récréation surtout la récréation bravo
Maxime vous les orientez vers de mauvais
chemins est-ce que les vacances sont
trop longues justement c'est la question
qu'on posait tout à l'heure sous forme
de de blague mais est-ce que c'est c'est
une réalité ces vacances sont trop
longues les rythmes scolaires je sais
pas si les vacances sont trop longues
mais je suis à peu près persuadé je
crois que je ne suis pas le seul que
l'année scolaire est trop courte alors
je vous laisse la responsabilité ensuite
de de trouver le bon équilibre vous
préférez pas trop vous engager sur ce
dossier là mais vous souhaiteriez tout
de même que les vacances soient plus
courtes l'été non c'est toutes PL entres
misise à part on sait que le débat sur
le rythme scolaire est compliqué dans
dans notre pays mais il y a tout de même
une réalité sur laquelle il y a un très
large consensus c'est sur l'idée que
nous sommes probablement le pays en
Europe qui a le nombre de jours de cours
le moins important et qui pourtant a les
programmes et souvent les horaires les
les plus lourds chercher l'erreur hein
donc il y a un vrai sujet nous imposons
aux élèves nous imposons au collégiens
et au lycéens encore des journées et des
semaines de travail qu'aucun adulte
n'accepterait de faire et ça ça demande
une vraie réflexion le ministre l'a
engagé alors tout le monde est d'accord
sur le constat on sait bien que dès
qu'il s'agit de proposer des solutions
ça devient un sujet plus sensible mais
je crois qu'une prise de conscience à ce
sujet est nécessaire et c'est pour ça
que vous le disiez tout à l'heure en
préambule c'est une année de transition
beaucoup de choses vont changer alors
par exemple est-ce qu'on va revenir aux
ufm ou en tout cas on va peut-être pas
les appeler ufm mais il y aura des des
instituts à la à venir c'est une des
pistes étudié alors ce qui est prévu
c'est effectivement de créer ce que nous
appelons des écoles supérieures du
professorat et et de l'éducation qui ont
vocation à former les futurs enseignants
et plus largement les personnels
d'éducation et ces écoles elles seront à
l'intérieur des universités parce que
c'est très important que dans notre pays
les universités qui forment les médecins
qui forment les juristes qui forment des
ingénieurs soient capable aussi de
former les les futurs maîtres hein comme
c'est le cas dans tous les pays
comparables aux nôtres et tout euh le le
travail que nous avons à conduire c'est
de faire en sorte que ces écoles soi
capable à la fois de donner au maîtres
un bon niveau de formation universitaire
dans les différentes disciplines qu'ils
auront à enseigner et en même temps soi
capable de leur donner une vraie
formation professionnelle pour les
préparer à l'exercice de leur métier
mais est-ce que les professeurs
resteront toutes leur vie des
professeurs parce que moi j'en ai
rencontré justement pendant une journée
d'accueil il y en a certains qui ont
déjà prévu un un plan B au cas où ils
perdent la flamme mais mais mais
pourquoi pas euh nous sommes à une
époque où les rythmes professionnels
évolue et il faut en effet pouvoir
évoluer il faut pouvoir changer et donc
il faut sans doute imaginer un système
qui permette d'entrer dans
l'enseignement à différents métiers à
différentes périodes de sa vie et et de
sa carrière pourquoi pas devenir
enseignant après avoir été professionnel
dans tel ou tel domaine hein de de
nombreuses années et apporter une
expérience originale et de la même
manière en effet il faut que les
enseignants puiss au besoin bifurquer
vers d'autres activités professionnelles
c'est l'évolution même de la profession
d'enseignant c'est difficile de gravir
des échelons le problème le problème que
nous avons de ce point de vue là dans
l'enseignement c'est qu'on travaille
avec des masses de personnel absolument
considérables donc quand vous travaillez
sur un million de personnes c'est très
difficile d'organiser leur mobilité
quels sont les employeurs dans le privé
ou même dans les collectivités
territoriales et cetera qui seraiit en
mesure de recruter autant d'enseignants
qui éventuellement voudrait pouvoir
évoluer donc le problème est un problème
de de nombre il n'est pas facile
d'organiser ni à l'intérie de
l'éducation nationale ni à l'extérieur
la mobilité suffisante c'est ce qui
explique que ça prenne du temps hein et
que ça appelle de de nouveaux modes de
d'organisation nouvelle organisation des
réformes à venir prochainement quelles
sont les réformes pour l'école en tant
que parents que vous attendez c'est une
question que nous sommes allés vous
poser aujourd'hui c'est l'une de nos
questions du jour de cette édition du
78 jusqu'on est des heures de cours et
des profs qui soit attentif ça serait
déjà un bon début ce que je pense des
réformes je voudrais qu'on arrête un
petit peu les réformes et qu'on commence
à travailler voilà je pense que ce qui
est le plus ennuyeux dans toutes ces
réformes c'est tout simplement que
chacun veut laisser sa patte et que
finalement on ne sait plus du tout où on
en est parce que chaque année on a une
nouvelle
réforme et chaque année on doit
s'adapter il est où l'enfant il est où
l'enseignant quand j'étais petite moi
j'avais j'en avais de l'éducation
civique ou ou de la morale à l'école
puis c'était bien je trouvais alors
peut-être ça va revenir je sais pas je
pense une meilleure formation des
professeurs ou des
instituteurs on voit qu'ils sont lancés
on va dire devant une classe sans
énormément de formation peut-être
prendre l'exemple sur les
professeurs expérimenter et pourquoi pas
être en doublon une année je vois mon
petit fils là il va ils sont 30 donc
déjà ça manque de maîtresse quoi parce
que là ils ont supprimé des
postes voilà pour C c'est quelques
quelques pistes qui ont été misises par
les téléspectateurs que nous avons
rencontré il y a des choses qui vous
semblent intéressantes des pistes à
creuser il il y a des choses très juste
je crois qu'une maire d'élèv disait il
faut cesser d'accumuler toujours des
réformes et je crois que dans l'esprit
du ministre l'idée de la refondation de
l'école c'est précisément le contraire
de l'accumulation et la stratification
des réformes a il y a quelques fils
conducteurs essentiels sur lesquel il
faut travailler pour réconcilier la
société française et l'école mais c'est
des choses simples hier vous savez nous
avons accueilli à trape le président de
la République qui venait visiter le le
collège Gagarine ou ou des équipes
extraordinaires par le motivation par
leur compétences font un travail tout à
fait remarquable pourquoi parce qu'ils
se sont saisis d'un sujet essentiel qui
est notamment la meilleure coordination
entre l'école primaire et le collège
comment faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus
de continuité plus de cohérence entre
les enseignements des écoles et et ceux
du collège ils travaillent avec leurs
collègues professeurs des écoles ils
imaginent ensemble des progressions des
évaluations ben voilà un sujet tout à
fait essentiel il y en a quelques autres
notamment une meilleure personnalisation
des enseignement au collège au lycée une
meilleure coordination avec
l'enseignement supérieur je crois que
les défis qui sont devant nous euh c'est
de creuser quelques sillons d'avancer
sur quelques dossiers aussi stratégiques
que que cela et de mobiliser toutes les
énergies sur ces sujets il y a des
dispositifs un peu test modèle dans dans
l'académie dans votre académie celle
celle de versaill par exemple je pense
au lycée de la nouvellechance à serg
Pontoise qui a été lancé ça très bon
projet qui est un très bon projet qui
pourra d'ailleurs concerner
éventuellement des élèves venant des des
ivelines l'idée est simple vous savez
qu'il y a à Versailles comme ailleurs
trop d'élèves qui abandonnent leur
scolarité en cours de route et qui
sortent du sème scolaire sans
qualification l'idée c'est comment faire
pour leur donner une deuxième chance et
pour leur donner la possibilité de
reprendre selon des modalités aménageres
une scolarité donc en effet le lycée
Cassel de sergie
Pontoise propose dès cette rentrée sous
la houlette d'un chefétablissement
dynamique d'une équipe très très motivée
un dispositif qui va permettre de donner
cette nouvelle chance à une cinquantaine
d'élèves ce sont des jeunes qui ont
abandonné leur scolarité qui ont eu une
année de années de difficulté qui
veulent reprendre hein et qui sont
recrutés sur la base d'un entretien de
motivation et qui se seront préparés au
baccalauréat avec évidemment des
pratiques pédagogiques adaptées un
système de tutorat parce que on
n'enseigne pas ce type d'élèves comme on
enseigne à un public classique voilà un
beau défi qu'une équipe très motivée là
aussi a entrepris de de relever des par
qui sont intéressés bien s on les
renvoie vers le rectorat s souhaitent en
savoir plus Le dispos nous les
accompagnons mieux au niveau des des
réformes juste pour conclure il y a deux
réunions qui sont à venir dans
l'académie 18 et 21 septembre du côté de
serg et de Savini aura d'ailleurs pas
dans dans les ivelines ça fait partie de
la grande concertation nationale autour
de la refondationé ces réunions elles
sont très
largementou à
tous l'idée c'est d'organiser deux
grands forum débat qui participent de la
concertation nationale qui est
actuellement en cours sur deux sujets
qui nous paraissent particulièrement
importants l'un que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure qui était le thème de la visite
du président de la République hier à
trppe c'est la liaison entre le premier
degré et le collège comment éviter les
les cloisonnements artificiel CEL et
comment construire une véritable
cohérence des des apprentissages le
deuxième sujet qui est également très
très important là nous nous réunirons à
à gevillier sur ce thème c'est comment
faire en sorte que les formations
professionnelles technologiques de
l'éducation nationale répondent mieux
aux besoins de l'économie vous savez que
tout le monde s'inquiète à juste titre
de la situation de l'emploi dans ce pays
mais tout le monde considère aussi qu'il
y a un décalage entre les besoins des
entreprises et les publics que que nous
formons et l'une des cl du redressement
productif comme on dit aujourd'hui c'est
de faire en sorte que notre appareil de
formation réponde mieux aux besoins de
de l'emploi et il y a là un beau défi
que nous avons entrepris déjà de de
relever dans l'académie nous y
travaillons avec la région Île-de-France
et je crois que peu à peu l'image de nos
lycées professionnels est en train de de
changer ces deux réunions auront lieu 18
et 21 septembre dans l'Académie de
versaill la concertation au niveau
national devrait s'acheter s'achever
pardon fin octobre et puis le projet de
loi ce sera pour la fin de l'année ce
pour Noël si tout va bien VO et on aura
l'occasion de vous faire revenir sur ce
plateau pour nous en parler merci d'être
venu sur le plateau merci également
Maxime vous allez nous quitter quelques
instants on va parler d'un tout autre
sujet l'été à la base de loisir été
difficile nous allons revenir sur
différents dossiers difficiles qui se
sont déroulés du côté de la de la base
de loisir notamment la noyade d'un
enfant de de 5 ans les responsables de
la base de loisir reviendront sur les
incidences sur cette catastrophe et bien
sûr sur ces incidences et Maxime donc
vous reviendrez en plateau on parlera
innovation avec vous ce sera la
chronique de l'innovation on va juste
regarder un dernier reportage concernant
cette rentr prcolaire cela concerne les
fournitures scolaires avec des parents
d'élèves qui s'inquiètent le coût de la
rentrée a progressé plus 2,9 % par
rapport à 2011 selon les dernières
estimations de famille de
France la rentrée c'était aujourd'hui
pour les parents l'heure est aussi à
l'achat des fournitures scolaires dans
cette enseigne spécialisée à montigi on
se prépare depuis quelques temps on
prépare les liste scolaire c'est veut
dire les clients peuvent nous envoyer
par fax par mail ou déposer une liste
ici on le prépare gratuitement il
viennent le payer comme ça ils
économisent beaucoup de
temps c'est donc l'iste en main que les
parents font leurs courses les revenus
les plus faibles disposeent d'une
allocation de rentrée pour les autres
c'est un véritable budget la rentrée
c'est une répense plus les différentes
affaires de sport et autres qu'il faut
renouveler donc c'est un gros budget
c'est un moi difficile on cherche ce qui
est sur la liste al généralement les
profs sont assez précis et exigeants
donc ma fille rentre au collège c'est
c'est la première fois qu'elle a une
liste assez chargée donc c'est la
première fois que je fais une rentrée
donc j'avais pas vraiment de budget
maintenant je me rends compte de ce que
ça coûte bah oui je suis déjà plus de
200 €
oui dans ce magasin on constate une
augmentation de 3 à 4 % du nombre de
clients le rush est attendu pour le
weekend
prochain